- [Voiceover] "The following
equation shows Kepler's 3rd Law
"of planetary motion.
"It relates the time, t (in days),
"that a planet takes to
revolve once around our sun
"to the distance, d (in kilometers),
"of that planet from the sun."
So, it tells us, t, how many
days, and it's in relation
to the distance that that
planet, in kilometers,
is from the sun.
"Mars is approximately 4 times as distant
"from the sun as Mercury is.
"About how many times longer would
"Mars's revolution time
be than for Mercury?
"Round your answer to the
nearest whole number."
So, let's think about it a little bit.
If you increased d by a factor of four,
if you increased d by a factor of four,
what's going to happen to t?
Well, if you increase
d by a factor of four,
you're going to notice you
take d to the third power.
So if you replace d with 4d,
so if you replace it with 4d,
you're going to get t squared is equal
to 3.98,
times 10 to the negative 20,
times 4d to the third power.
Well, 4d to the third power,
four is going to be the same thing,
I could rewrite that as four to the third,
times d to the third.
Four to the third power, that's
16 times four, that's 64.
So, it's going to be the same thing as 64,
times d to the third power.
Or I could just write this
as d to the third power,
and then all of that times 64.
Now, we have to be careful here.
We might say, "Hey, look, this expression
on the right side is 64 times
this expression right over here."
When we increased d by a factor of four,
the right side becomes 64 times as big,
because, remember, four
to the third power.
If this becomes 4d, this
becomes 64, d to the third,
which we saw right over there.
But on the left hand side,
you have a t squared.
You have a t squared.
So, over here, you would
get that t is equal
to the principal root
of all of this business right
over here, the 3.98 times ten
to the negative 20, times d to the third.
Here, you're going to get
t is going to be equal
to the principal root
of 3.98 times 10 to the negative 20,
times d to the third, times,
you could throw the 64
under the radical, or you could say,
times the principal root of 64.
Well, the principal root of 64 is eight.
So, times eight.
So, when you look at it this way,
you increase d by a factor of four,
you're going to increase
t by a factor of eight.
This expression is the same
thing as this expression,
but we have a times eight here now.
So about how many times
longer would Mars's
revolution time be than for Mercury?
Well, eight times longer.